I know you are wondering
what coin flipping has to do
with k-means clustering.
I promise I will explain in this section.
And in the previous section,
we learned that, if HiddenVector is known,
we can derive Parameters
through dot products.
But, in reality, neither HiddenVector
nor Parameters are known,
and therefore, it is unclear how
to derive the biases of the coin.
Let's start from a simple problem.
Let's imagine for a second that
Parameters are actually known.
Let's start from this example.
Parameters are 0.35 for the
blue coin, 0.80 for the green coin.
Can we derive HiddenVector?
Well let's say what the most likely
coin is to generate the first
sequence of flips, where the
fraction of heads is 0.4.
Well, we can compute the probability
that the first sequence
was generated by the blue coin,
and this probability
turns out to be 0.00113.
We can also compute
the probability that it was
generated by the green coin, and it turns
out to be much smaller number: 0.00003.
Which coin is more likely?
Of course, the blue coin is more
likely to generate the first sequence.
Which coin is more likely to generate the
second sequence, with nine heads?
Well, we do the same calculation, and
it turns out that the probability of
the second series of flips to
be generated by the blue coin
is much smaller than the probability of
it being generated by the green coin.
Therefore, the most likely coin for
the second series of flips is green.
And by continuing this way,
we can derive HiddenVector.
And it brings us to the following idea:
Yes, we do not know the parameters or
HiddenVector when we start
evaluating the biases of the coins.
But let's start from
randomly chosen parameters.
As soon as Parameters are chosen,
we can derive HiddenVector.
As soon as HiddenVector is derived,
we question our wisdom in selecting
the initial Parameters and
estimate Parameters using Data
and HiddenVector as I described before,
through the dot product. In this
way, we will arrive at the new parameters.
As soon as the new Parameters are derived,
we once again want to evaluate
the HiddenVector and iterate.
We came up with an approximation algorithm
for evaluating parameters for the coin flip,
and let me show you how this algorithm works.
We start from randomly selected Parameters.
As soon as Parameters are selected,
we form HiddenVector,
so we assign each series of flips to
either the blue coin the or red coin.
As soon as HiddenVector is derived,
we can use this HiddenVector
to derive new parameters.
As soon as these new parameters are derived,
we construct a new HiddenVector,
and we iterate until convergence.
Does this algorithm remind you of something?
Of course! It is the k-means algorithm,
or something very similar to
the Lloyd algorithm in disguise.
Where are Data, HiddenVector, and
parameters in k-means clustering?
Well, Data are obviously
the set of data points.
What are Parameters?
Parameters of course
are the positions of the Centers.
And what is HiddenVector?
HiddenVector is simply the assignment
of data points to k centers,
Which is an N-dimensional vector
with coordinates from 1 to k.
This assignment HiddenVector is
shown below by the green coordinates.
So, we figured out how to solve
the coin flipping problem and
what relationship it has
to k-means clustering, and
now we'll talk about a more general
approach called "expectation maximization".